>> Larry: WELCOME BACK.
NOW, IN HONOR OF THE INDIANA
PIZZA STORY, IT IS TIME FOR A
GAME WE ARE CALLING
PIZZA-SEXUALITY.
THE NAME SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
THIS IS THE EPITOME OF
PIZZA-SEXUALITY.
>> SO PANELISTS, THERE YOU GO,
SEE?  I WILL NAME A KIND OF
PIZZA AND HERE IS HOW IT WORKS
AND YOU HAVE TO TELL US WHETHER
YOU HE THAT BY   IS A IS
LESBIAN, GAY, BI, TRANS OR
STRAIGHT.
>> ONLY GET TO CHOOSE FROM THOSE
CATEGORIES??
>> Larry: OR PIZZA. IT IS LIKE
50 IF WE'RE FOLLOWING FACEBOOK
RULES. SO I WILL GIVE YOU
CORRECT ANSWER
AND AWARD MADE-UP POINTS. WE'RE
JUST GONNA
MAKE THIS (BLEEP) UP AS WE
GO ALONG.
>> SO LIKE THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
>> Larry: EXACTLY AND THE
WINNER WILL GET WHATEVER IS IN
THE PIZZA BOX.
I WON'T TELL YOU WHAT'S IN IT
BUT THE WINNER WILL GET THAT.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE FRESH, HOT
AND DELICIOUS, I TELL YOU THAT.
IT SAYS RIGHT THERE.
>> OKAY.
FIRST UP, MEAT LOVERS PIZZA.
ALL RIGHT?  IS THIS PIZZA --
>> DO YOU SAY GAY?
>> 100,000 PERCENT GAY.
>> Larry: DAVE?
>> YEAH, I THINK MEAT LOVERS IS
A CERTAIN KIND OF GAY PIZZA.
>> REALLY?
>> EVERYBODY CHOOSES GAY.
SORRY THE CORRECT ANSWER IS
LESBIAN.
ALL RIGHT.
JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE LESBIANS
DOESN'T MEAN THEY DON'T LIKE
MEAT.
THAT IS YOUR HATE.
OKAY?
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT.
AND I GUESS IT DEPENDS ON THE
INDIVIDUAL TOPPINGS.
NO.
NO THAT IS YOUR HATE.
STUFFED CRUST PIZZA WITH THE
CHEESE ALL UP IN THAT CRUST LIKE
THAT.
IS THAT --
>> IS THAT LESBIAN, GAY, BI,
TRANS OR STRAIGHT?
>> I THINK THAT IS THE
HOMOPHOBIC PIZZA.
>> Larry: HOMOPHOBIC?
>> IT IS SO COMPLICATED.
THAT HAS TO BE LESBIAN?
>>
>> BECAUSE IT IS COMPLICATED.
>> GAY RAPPER PIZZA.
>> Larry: GAY RAPPER.
>> BECAUSE IT'S ALL UP IN THAT
(BLEEP)
>> Larry: THAT IS A HECK OF AN
ANSWER.  THE CORRECT ANSWER IS,
YOU KNOW, THE PIZZA IS HEDGING
ITS BETS.
IS IT A PIZZA, IS IT A CALZONE?
MAYBE IT'S BOTH.
A BISEXUAL PIZZA.
>> Larry: YOU CAN HAVE IT YOUR
WAY.
EXACTLY.
>> I RESPECT A PIZZA THAT'S
HALF-AND-HALF.
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT.
CHICAGO STYLE DEEP DISH PIZZA.
>> I'M SORRY, LARRY, THAT IS NOT
PIZZA.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Larry: THAT SOUNDS GOOD
ENOUGH!  I THINK THAT ANSWER
WINS IT AND YOU GET THE 100
PIZZA ADDITION RIGHT THERE.
THERE YOU GO.
WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK RIGHT
AFTER THIS!